thank you everyone for coming here
um today we're going to talk about how
to win at uh monetizing games as a
service uh I am Mike Nadal I'm a data
and analytics specialist working at
Google Cloud I work with a number of
different game studios on issues just
like this as well as everything else
that's data analytics I'm also here with
Ari wolf hi everyone my name is Ari wolf
I'm a machine learning solution
specialist I'm a Google Cloud for games
team so essentially my role is to help
customers better use vertex AI which is
our Ai and ml Suite made available in
the cloud
cool so before we get too much further
into this a couple quick housekeeping
notes please make sure to turn off all
of your potential noise makers
um that's kind of first and foremost
second I will remind you at the very end
but if you could fill out the survey
provide any feedback that would be
fantastic
third is if this isn't the talk that
you're here for it is way too awkward to
get up and leave now so sorry you're
stuck here
so uh with that I think we can go ahead
and dive in so here are the goals for
today uh we knocked out the
introductions good to go there second
thing we're going to talk about is uh
the first thing that anybody ever taught
me about machine learning was
um you got to have your data solution
figured out garbage in garbage out and
so the first thing we want to cover off
on is how to unify your data and make
the most of that
next thing we're going to dive into and
this is where Aria is going to take over
is how to start integrating machine
learning into all of your monetization
strategies and what that looks like
specifically in Google Cloud
and then last but certainly not least
we'll save time for questions if you're
brave enough to ask questions here we
are more than happy to answer them as
well but uh we'll also be here
throughout the conference and then also
directly after the talk if there are
things you want to ask us specifically
this is the one slide so if you happen
to doze off throughout the rest of the
talk or if there's some other things
that distract you this is the one slide
that you manage to ingest
we're going to be happy so the key
takeaways that we'll start on I'll do
the first two since they're more data
specific uh the
this one's always tough for me but you
have to focus on data governance and I
say it's tough because I know that it's
really hard and also extremely boring so
um but being able to build that
data-driven culture being able to make
it easy to stick to that data driven
culture
is absolutely key to a number of
different goals that you'd like to
accomplish using that data so not only
monetization but anything else that
happens to fall under the realm of data
analytics
the second thing is start small but
think big and what this really entails
is a lot of times when you are looking
to tackle these problems there's a lot
of siled data that you have to desilo
there are a lot of teams and politics
that you have to play towards in order
to start accomplishing the goals that
you have set out to accomplish
um
start small by picking like a select
number of data sets and validating your
idea and once you have that flesh out
what the production level version of
that use case is going to look like
and with that I'll hand it over to Ari
for the next three great yeah so in the
second half of the session we're going
to discuss how you can leverage and melt
enhanced monetization so we're going to
focus on some foundational ml use cases
that we feel like any practitioner
should have in their toolkit we also
don't believe in building models for the
sake of building models models are meant
to be put into production and action
upon so we'll talk about some activation
scenarios on how you can leverage these
model outputs
and then finally we'll wrap up the sense
the session talking about how you can
evolve your ml stress strategy over time
with automation then briefly touch on
quantifying business impact with a B
experiments
fantastic so let's dive into what it
means to unify your data so when we
think about uh the experience of
developing live games or games as a
service these days
um a lot of it has evolved into what we
see here where it's more than just
making the actual game itself which is
already hard enough but needing to
figure out how to develop a long-term
relationship focus with your customers
being able to Target that relationship
with the right advertising the right
in-game offers being able to enhance or
augment the gameplay itself based on the
signals that those customers are sending
to you and in order to do really any of
the things that you see up here you need
to have a good grasp of data and what
we've found in working with a number of
different Studios is that they're
actually producing all of this data they
have more data than they can really
stomach at this point and so
once they have that actual data itself
what they start to figure out is okay we
need to figure out
in this slide essentially what's the
difference between the first party data
that I have and the third party data
that I have and how do I take that to
start tackling some of the use cases I'd
like to focus on so from left to right
here real-time game experiences so this
one's going to be a little bit more
complex but again once you get a handle
on things like operational data game
data Telemetry itself and if you're able
to start integrating that with some of
the third-party data that things like
you know Google provides or apple
provides even meta provides then that's
when you're able to start getting a
better understanding of what are some
timely in-game offers that I can make to
my players based on the data that
they're sending to us either based on
how they're playing the game itself or
offers that they are accepting or
rejecting
once you have a solid understanding of
how your players are engaging that's
when you can start moving moving into
improving retention and monetization so
a lot of the focus is initially on okay
first is my game good enough that
players are willing to play it by
getting the signals at all
first hurdle to clear but then once you
do start to understand what's making
your customers stick around what's
making them leave and being able to
build on top of that with built-in
recommendations so we'll talk about
we'll talk a little bit about how that
looks in just the world of data
analytics and then evolve on that a
little bit more with AI and ml itself
uh these next two are where the idea of
data governance really starts to come
into play uh being able to share that
data across the organization is really
what makes uh these use cases into
something that is much more impactful to
the studio itself so uh while each
individual team might have their own
perspective on how to operate and and
function in the world of their known
data sets being able to take those data
sets and merge them across team wherever
it makes sense is really where we start
to see the uh the most benefit gained
from all the data collaboration that you
can put into place now the important
part about being able to tackle that is
being able to do so while protecting
user data and operating with trust the
second that either there's a user data
week or there's
um improper pii handling that happens
within your organization
that's that's a killer every data
analogy six uh proposals that you put
into place from that point forward is
going to have a little Cloud over it and
that's what we want to try to avoid so
once you're able to tackle all of those
things the comprehensive Insight that
you're able to gain from first and
third-party data is what's going to
build the most success towards uh
tackling the games in today's
environment so
um this is kind of what the current set
of silos tends to look like at any given
studio
um whether you're in marketing revenue
or in operations you're going to have
different goals that you are tasked with
accomplishing and sometimes as a line
sometimes they don't really
but for us what we'd like to be able to
do and you've probably seen a side like
this before either directly from Google
or a number of other vendors the what we
want to emphasize here is that while the
silos do exist we don't necessarily when
we say desolate we don't necessarily
mean that you need to take every bit of
data and put it all into one database or
one data warehouse what we would like to
emphasize as part of the solutions that
we'll talk about in just a second is
develop a metadata understanding of that
data where it lives who has access to it
and who should have access to it and
once you do that breaking down the silos
that exists between those teams is
really just a matter of getting the
right permissions to access that data
um the benefit of being able to do that
is uh
once those silos are broken down a
little bit from that metadata
perspective tackling all the various use
cases that are critical to you each one
of those teams becomes much more simple
but then more advanced use cases such as
dynamically changing gameplay experience
or dynamically offering based on
recommendations start to become much
more viable as well
um and so with that super quickly we
should Define how Google thinks of data
governance itself since it's kind of a
loaded phrase
um and you know as as you stated a
little bit earlier it might not be the
most fun but you can kind of think about
it like hey I need to collect all three
of the the data governance jewels and uh
I'm on a quest to do so
still kind of boring
um but that's okay so the main three
things that we think about are
data security the equality and data
compliance so if you're able to what I
would say is uh focus on a charter the
culture of data governance before you
start to dive into what technology is
going to help me tackle data governance
if you start from technology and focus
on that as your data governance solution
you're going to run into a lot of issues
you're probably going to fail to be
honest
um because you are instantly limited by
the capabilities of that technology
itself whereas if you have a charter
that the company can agree on that you
all can stick to no matter what
technology you use then you're in a much
stronger position because you can fit
that technology to your need and for us
it's being able to understand again who
has access to the data that is currently
available to your company
um security also entails what people are
doing with that data there have been a
number of customers that we've worked
with that um have told us you know we
found a data pipeline that was spun up
we don't really know who spun it up but
it is boarding out customer data and we
uh just hope that that's something that
is coming from inside of our studio and
we want to avoid that so the next is
data quality so again that whole concept
of garbage in garbage out
is centered around what tool sets are
available in order to make things like
standardization data life cycles that
much easier to work with and easier is a
very key point there because the harder
that you make it to follow the
guidelines that you lay out in your data
governance Charter the easier it's going
to be for people to kind of try to
bypass it or just get their day job done
so being able to automate a lot of the
data quality issues that people run into
is going to be foundational to making
sure that the data governance plan that
you create and some using it you can
stick to
last but not least data compliance there
are a number of compliance regulations
that we as a uh
are we in the the gaming vertical have
to start thinking about whether it's
gdpr
um or really any other compliance
standard that's out there uh being able
to audit and classify data and ensure
that when you are operating on that data
if you have an idea in mind that the
data that you're looking at is something
that is clean
and is it contains data that you're
supposed to be looking at is
Paramount so
once we're able to kind of handle all
three of those and if you have a game
plan for tackling those three you're
going to be in a pretty good place and
that's something that you shouldn't
necessarily create one draft of and then
you're done as you release that draft
and start to iterate on it work with it
within your studio
you'll start to understand what parts do
we need to change and what pieces of
Technology would actually make sense to
add in order to benefit the game plan
that you set out here
so with that it's time to dive into a
super complex data architecture
um not really though it's uh for the
most part when you're tackling all these
problems in gcp it's just bigquery
um what started out as really just a
simple data warehouse is actually
started to evolve into a data platform
and so a lot of the use cases that we've
talked about so far are things that you
can actually accomplish purely using
bigquery there are definitely more
advanced versions of uh data
architectures that you can put into
place when you're operating in bigquery
but again if you remember that second
Point start small think big what we see
people use bigquery for a lot is uh
prototyping ideas for other teams to
take and advance and you know much more
complicated Fashions but what we want to
be able to do is Empower people with
some of the more basic things that you
can do with just SQL with just the uis
that are built into bigquery itself and
running with that so what we're going to
do
is start at the top and kind of work our
way clockwise and try to get an
understanding of how each one of these
systems works with bigquery and then
what we'll do is we'll dive into those
in individual slides so we can get a
better understanding of what that looks
like so uh from the top marketing
campaigns and Revenue data a lot of just
purely built-in connectors that work
directly with bigquery so if you're
looking to port in marketing data if you
have CRM data that is important to uh
better understanding what your player is
doing where they're doing it and how you
can message back to them
all that can happen just directly via
built-in connectors in bigquery
operational data I think is particularly
important something that is near and
dear to my heart what that usually ends
up meaning is creating streaming data
pipelines and the cool thing about
bigquery is whether you want to batch or
stream data in you can make that happen
without having to necessarily use a
different system we are going to talk
through what a version of that system
would look like so you can start making
a lot more real-time decisions based on
the signals that you are getting
next when you dive into things like
machine learning and security and
governance machine learning is actually
built directly into bigquery so with no
more than three SQL queries you can
actually train your model evaluate your
model and then actually implement the
model itself so that you can save
yourself some very expensive machine
learning scientist hours and if it's
just in analytics idea that you want to
put into place and validate then that's
something that you can start to tackle
with bqml the next thing is security and
governance and uh the key phrases that
we want to jot down here are going to be
dataplex and big lake so we're going to
come back to those ideas but those are
integrated directly into bigquery so
when you have data that lives in
bigquery itself but also data that can
live in a number of other disparate
systems those are all things that you
can have control over so that when
people are running their marketing
analytics or if they're doing in-game
crash report analytics whatever it may
be they have access to the right data
sets and if they need to get access to
those other data sets they have a means
to be able to do that
down here where we have identified the
individual teams themselves marketing
teams uh Revenue teams and operations
teams those are delineations that you
can make using dataplex so that when a
team is looking to interact with any
data set that lives in bigquery
they are already part of a given team
that has its set rules and boundaries
for how they interact with data and
those are things that you can control
and evolve over time
last is data sharing both with Partners
but then also across teens so we have a
tool set that we've developed that lives
on top of bigquery called analytics Hub
which has really made data sharing
within bigquery that much easier and so
you'll notice with uh this and machine
learning and security governance there's
bi-directional arrows and the purpose
for that is we want to be able to
uh have that be a relationship that
shares data back and forth so the data
is constantly evolving how you look at
the use cases that you want to be able
to tackle are all also something that
you can kind of take into account as
time goes by
these are all individual building blocks
some of them you can take advantage of
right out of the gate other ones you're
going to set up over time some of them
you may need now and some of them you
could do without and that's totally fine
this is an example of putting everything
together all in one basket and what
we'll do is dive into what
each one of those individual building
blocks looks like so you can figure out
does this make sense for the use cases
that I want to tackle and uh if not
figure out where they fit in the future
so the first thing we'll dive into is
game dated Telemetry so operational data
in particular when we're trying to
understand if there are exploits
happening in our system if there are
game crashes that are happening and we
want to be able to action on those types
of things
um this is a fairly basic but
um also pretty straightforward uh
implementation of what that Telemetry
example would look like so for us there
are two new technologies that we
introduced here we won't spend a ton of
time on those because they each could be
their own one hour presentation but
dataflow is our managed version of
Apache beam which is a open source tool
for batch and stream and uh what you're
going to end up using that for is when
you get that raw data in there's a good
chance that you're going to want to
transform it maybe it's in proto format
it's nested and you want to get it into
uh row format for bigquery whatever it
may be
there's windows sessioning and
aggregation that you can do in dataflow
as well as data Transformations that
allow you to get data from point A to
point B while transforming it along the
way
Pub sub is a A system that we have for
ingesting a number of small messages
really at incredible speeds and the most
important thing about both of these is
really that they are fully uh fully
managed so when you're starting to think
about how we want to build out these
style of pipelines but you don't want to
spend a ton of engineering hours on
building them out a lot of what people
are building these days stems from being
able to do so without having to manage
the actual underlying infrastructure
so uh what we'll see here on the right
is a live gameplay data source that's
going to drop data into Pub sub as
purely an event collector from there it
you'll route that through dataflow
itself and from dataflow you can
determine which one of the topics that
are located in Pub sub doesn't make
sense to land this data in is the use
case something that's more so centered
around real-time alerting are you
looking to do uh to Port that data out
to some third-party services that are
dependent on it do you want to land that
data directly in bigquery or really any
other data sync that you could possibly
think of
that's what this style of system is
going to be able to accomplish so
um that's how we end up tackling
operational data that can be a
fundamental part of understanding what
it looks like to take that data make the
most of it and
um from there what we can start to dive
into as well is uh what the big lake and
database dataplex integration looks like
in bigquery so these were the two that
we wanted you to hold on to for a little
bit while we dive into what they
actually look like so dataplex itself is
a user interface that is built into
bigquery and it's going to be much more
focused on understanding your data from
a metadata layer so there's things like
Auto Discovery security and governance
that you can put into place you can
slice and dice your data in a number of
different ways that are pertinent to the
actual teams themselves so in creating
one of the the newer catchphrases that
we have called a data mesh
that's where we start to focus more so
on
how do we distribute the state data
based on the teams that it's important
to versus just creating a purely like
bronze silver and gold version of the
data so
the other cool things that you can start
to dive into with dataplex are things
like data lifecycle management so when
you look into archival data and
understanding when it makes sense to
move something in archival data or if
you want to automate data quality tasks
like better understanding if there
should be should or should not be null
values if there are expected values that
you can start to tackle then those are
all things that you can start to
automate with dataplex itself
big lake is when we start to dive into a
lot more of the data governance
implementation of all of the
of all the data that we've discussed so
far so being able to implement things
like fine-grained access access control
which is in particular
row and column level security so when
people are again operating on data and
they just run a query they'll know that
the data that they get back is something
that they're supposed to be looking at
it's already safe and secure you're good
to go there are a number of other
benefits where wherever you see fit so
when you want to start optimizing for
asset transactions being able to write
faster again things that are much more
advanced implementations of your use
case once you validate your initial idea
the other benefit of really all of these
systems is that whether your data is
structured semi-structured even
unstructured if it lives in Google Cloud
if it lives in another third-party
provider if lives on-prem there are
another number of different ways that
this API implementation can access that
data and give you that understanding of
that data really no matter where it
lives because what we'd like to have you
do is again first instead of building
out a data pipeline that's going to
migrate that data directly into bigquery
and then working on it there validate
the idea first then build the data
pipeline save yourself some time and
effort
[Music]
last thing we want to dive into as we
start to piece together what all the
individual blocks look like is the
analytics Hub architecture so analytics
Hub is going to be the uh the the
version of tool sets that we've put into
place that allow you to share data not
only across your organization but also
to third-party services so when we think
about how do you monetize the data that
we're generating itself this is also
what we can start to put into place and
so the architecture that we see here
um analytics Hub is going to be in the
middle you will have the data publisher
itself so that's going to be the team
that actually generates the data and
then from there what you're going to
have is a data subscriber so they're
going to be able to search the uh
exchanges and listings that analytics
Hub makes available and see just kind of
what data is out there what data can I
start to play with and the the cool
thing is that this all works in tandem
with things like dataplex in Big Lake so
that when you are searching through
those exchanges and listings you see the
data that is most part most pertinent to
you and also data that you should be
seeing and that you're able to operate
on
and really the whole system is put into
place so that it can make the original
idea of sticking to the data governance
Charter that you put into place as easy
as possible
um this is a little bit of an eye chart
I hope that you have some megapixels on
your camera but happy to uh share this
slide out with with anybody that's
interested as well but this is just an
example of uh being able to take all
this and pizza together to tackle
something like customized gameplay
um and so really the solution here is
taking your data sets whether that's
things like current and past inventory
of your game players uh or uh instances
of purchases that they've made storing
that in your data warehouse but then
also being able to operate on it and
create multiple segments based on those
players are they high skill but low
Spenders are they low skill but High
Spenders that would be me
and once you have those segments what do
you use or how do you start to optimize
towards
these type of recommendations that you'd
like to build out with them so are there
recommended builds that you'd like them
to tackle are there quests that you
should highlight requests that you
should de-prioritize based on the
playstyles that they have are there
offers that you've sent out in the store
itself that may not have landed with
that particular user and are there new
ones that you can then start to Showcase
them as well
um all of that you can actually tackle
just using the tools that we've talked
about so far once we start to dive into
things like vertex AI which Aria's going
to talk about in just a little bit you
can start to see how to make those that
much more advanced
um
once you have an idea of all these tool
sets that you'd like to be able to piece
together
you can start to really not only handle
the basics some of the things that we
see up here some of the things that
you're probably tasked with today either
optimizing Market spend or getting to
users before they churn but then you can
also start diving into some of your more
advanced use cases like customizing
gameplay
and to really put this into a more
concrete fashion I usually don't like
these kind of slides where it's you know
fairly salesy here's a uh a customer
that you know obviously they they
doubled their click-through rate and
half their costs in order to do so
sounds fantastic but really for me the
most important thing here is two things
the first is the quote on the right and
that Google was able to help us build
this solution and this is important
because what we're not selling you is uh
you know big game monetization it is a
series of tool sets that you can use to
best Implement what this solution looks
like for you
and what we'd love to be able to do is
work together with your Studios to best
tailor the solutions that we have to the
problems that you're trying to solve the
second thing is if you're interested in
learning more about how Square Enix
themselves have actually tackled this
problem and implemented what this
unified data platform looks like they're
giving a talk later on today in this
very room I think it's at 210 to 240 and
they'll walk you through what that
implementation looked like
and with that I will hand it off to good
friend hirari and we'll talk some more
ml
[Music]
great so we wanted to kick off this
section on enhancing monetization with
ML with a quote from a professor Peter
fader so it basically says if you can't
sort out your customers if you can't
look at them and know who's good who's
bad then you can't be player-centric or
customer Centric
so what I really like about this quote
is that it really gets to the heart of
how machine learning can age your
monetization efforts because it can
really help you understand you know
which customers or players do I really
need to focus on
and potentially which customers should I
avoid or de-prioritize in a lot of cases
so machine learning can enhance
modernization in a few different ways
that we'll walk through uh throughout
the presentation uh the first one is to
increase player acquisition so
essentially you can leverage machine
learning to get a better sense for
players who are more likely to buy
install subscribe and essentially
reach those prospects with ads to
incentivize them to take that action
another potential application of machine
learning is to better manage your Advent
ad inventory so machine learning is a
great way to better understand you know
who should receive an ad should I save
an ad slot for myself or should I
potentially sell that ad slot to an
Advertiser if you're a publisher in this
case
Mike touched on churn to a certain
extent so machine learning is a really
great way to understand which customers
are on the verge of lapsing
so it's a common use case I think it's
one use case that most people are
familiar with but it's something that
you should definitely lean into out of
the gate
you can leverage recommendation systems
and custom segmentations to enhance
personalization so that's another use
case that we'll dive into in a bit
and then uh one lesser use case that I
feel like is often overlooked is
leveraging machine learning to increase
cpms so again this is tailored towards a
publisher in this case but you could
often use curated audiences Google has
their own proprietary audiences that
they sell
to allow your advertisers to Target
those audiences and you could get an
increased CPM in that case so it's
directly enhancing your revenue and your
monetization strategy
foreign
so we will start off with uh the the
base use case of predicting churn so one
persistent problem that a lot of gaming
companies face is that there is a lot of
games there's increased competition in a
lot of cases gaming companies are vying
for players attention and retention
attention and retention has become a
problem so one stat that we often see
across gaming companies is that only uh
they only gaming companies only see a 25
retention rate for users after the first
day so obviously that's not very high
lapsing is is a persistent problem that
we want to keep in check so one approach
that a lot of gaming companies face is
combining their behavioral data with
their demographic demographic data to
build models that are going to indicate
or predict which players are on the cusp
elapsing within the first 24 hours so
that you could have some sort of
intervention whether that be a promo
promotion or something sort of offer so
that hopefully you can keep that those
players as a customer
so another challenge that gaming
companies face is sorting through you
know the Myriad number of players that
they're working with and trying to
understand who are the really high value
players and who are the low value
players who should I de-prioritize and
who should I really spend a lot of time
on
so you might ask yourself you know why
should I lean into predictive lifetime
value modeling and I really find these
two figures or data data nuggets really
impactful uh it's actually five times
more expensive to acquire a new player
than an existing player so really
maintaining your current player base is
of utmost importance
and then oftentimes when we do
predictive lifetime value modeling we
find that it's a certain subset of your
player base that's generating a lot of
your Revenue so time and time again we
see this same statistic or Benchmark but
oftentimes 20 of your players are
accounting for upwards of 80 of your
Revenue so really sifting through that
Consignment then of players and figuring
out who's high value and who Lo whose
low value is really important
um so I'm not really into figures and uh
differ diagrams but I actually do really
like this diagram on the right hand side
of the screen it basically showcases if
you treat all of your players the same
you're actually leaving a lot of money
on the table
so by treating all of your players the
same you're likely under investing in
your highest value players which is the
two bars that you would see on the left
hand side and you're over investing in
your low value players which are which
is the two bars that you see on the
right hand side so we know that players
aren't created equal so predictive
lifetime value is a good way to
understand who to spend time on who not
to spend time on
so let's bring this uh to life a little
bit we said that we don't want to build
models for the sake of building models
so we're going to walk you through
several actionable steps that you can
take or activation scenarios which is
what we like to call them but you can
essentially use machine learning to
improve the return on on investment of
your player acquisition player
acquisition efforts with modeled
audiences so here's an example of how
this might work
so essentially you could build a model
based off of an app event level data
because we're Google we just used one of
our martech tools so ga360 it's a
martech tool that we're using in this
case
so let's say we build a model based off
of the signals within that app Analytics
tool we can then import those
predictions and set up a workflow or a
pipeline to bring those model outputs or
model scores back into your martech tool
and what that allows you to do is within
the martech tool itself create segments
that you can then pass to different ad
buying platforms this is very Google
Centric but this is possible outside of
Google as well but this would
essentially allow you to to pass modeled
audience list to a display in video 360
or Google ads so that you can Target or
reach those users with media in order to
retain them
so one question you're probably asking
you know is this possible with game
Telemetry data this same thing is POS
possible with game to limit to Telemetry
data you can also also build these same
models off that type of data set I will
call out that the way that you would
activate is slightly different so you
wouldn't have the same workflow that we
have up on the screen but a lot of Media
Partners whether that be Facebook or
Google you can send them custom lists
that you can onboard into these buying
platforms on the right hand side which
allows you to reach those those
audiences with ads
so another activation scenario or way
that you can action off model outputs is
by combining uh model outputs themselves
and actually I'm fond of this activation
scenario myself
so in this example we've trained two
different models so we've trained a
churn model in a predictive lifetime
value model which you see in the chart
at the bottom left hand corner and what
we've done is we've essentially
multiplied the two values together so if
we look at the top row we multiply 0.6
by 500 to get essentially a new metric
which we're calling expected value at
risk which again looking at the first
row is three hundred dollars and what I
really like about this approach is it
allows you to understand where to
prioritize
so for example if your cost to reach a
customer and when I say customer I mean
a player if your cost to reach a player
exceeds that of your expected value at
risk that's someone that you don't want
to spend a lot of time on
whereas if your expected value at risk
greatly exceeds your cost to reach the
customer those are the people that you
really want to lean into and again going
through this metaphor of gaming
companies or are constantly going
through this Consignment been of players
and trying to figure out where to spend
time this is a good way to do that
so the next two use cases that we'll
focus on are surrounding how to
personalize The Experience so we'll talk
through a data driven segmentation and
recommendation systems but
personalization is very important and
time and time again we see that
personalization really enhances
monetization we actually see that
customers are 40 percent more likely to
spend more when they get some sort of
curated or tailored experience so it's
something that customers at the end of
the day have come to expect in a lot of
cases
um so this example is specific to a data
data driven segmentation so what we've
done in this case is we've leveraged a
clustering algorithm there's a lot of
different flavors or types of clustering
algorithms but we've essentially broken
out our player base into six different
cohorts
so essentially what that would allow us
to do is after we've used the clustering
algorithm we've come up come up with our
cohorts you can then essentially profile
those uh those different clusters and
then based on what you learn from that
profiling exercise figure out how do you
want to tailor that experience
experience so that it resonates with a
given player
um so at Google we always ask you know
why care uh so why would you want to do
this exercise so in a lot of ways it's
going to increase retention and
engagement uh and it also really moves a
lot of business metrics so I feel like
churn has been kind of a common theme
throughout my talk so far it helps to
reduce Churn it really helps to not only
improve engagement but also increase
your average revenue per user so since
this talk is focused on monetization
this is one approach that will really
help to move the move the needle
so there's another way to tackle a
personalization and it's via building a
recommendation system there's a lot of
different ways to build a recommendation
system for Matrix Matrix factorization
to two Tower encoders there's a lot of
different flavors but at its most basic
level with the recommendation system you
leverage two different data sets so
you'll leverage an item catalog and
you'll leverage event level data
and based after you've trained your
recommendation system using those two
base data sets what it allows you to do
is you can offer up a personalized item
to every given user
so comparing the the data driven
segmentation into the recommendation
system I would say the segmentation
allows you to learn a little bit more
about your players because you're going
through this exercise of profiling them
and understanding them you don't have
that same benefit from recommendation
systems but recommendation systems are
impactful from a monetization and
revenue perspective
so at Google Cloud we have you know
multiple flavors of recommendation
systems and we always see that it moves
the needle when it comes to revenue and
we've seen up to a 50 lift in revenue
and up to a five percent lift in total
revenue per session so it's really going
to help enhance uh Revenue within your
organization
so going back to you know what can I do
with these model outputs how can I
activate we wanted to walk you through
some examples on how you could activate
off off of a data-driven segmentation so
we talked through one of these already
but one way to increase your cpms if
you're a publisher is to essentially
sell these proprietary audiences for an
increased CPM Google actually does it
this themselves Facebook does it as well
they basically offer up their own
personal audiences that you can Target
at an additional cost so that's one way
to activate off of this type of scenario
the other way to leverage
um a data driven segmentation is to use
it to better decision your ads to given
users so in this case you would use an
ad management platform to say based on
what I know about this given cohort I'm
going to send them this uh specific
creative because I know it's going to
resonate with them because they like dog
cats or whatever they care about
so wrapping up with the use cases and
then we'll walk into evolving your ml
strategy the final use case that we
wanted to talk through is leveraging
machine learning to predict some sort of
outcome and enhance acquisition so what
we mean in that case is how can we
leverage machine learning to predict
someone's likelihood to install
subscribe or buy so there's there's a
lot of different flavors of this
what's interesting about this use case
is logistically it's very similar to
your churn model the only thing that
you're doing in this case is you're
changing the outcome that you're trying
to predict so try rather than trying to
predict someone's likelihood of lapsing
we're trying to predict someone's
likelihood to to buy or install or
subscribe so your label is just changing
in this case
so I'm actually
um really fond of this scenario as well
so the way that you can action off of
these player acquisition models is using
using it to better Med manage your own
ad inventory
so in this example you would essentially
onboard these segments into your ad
management platform and what I like
about this example is you can learn just
as much about a high likelihood from a
high likelihood as you can about from a
low likelihood
so the three segments that we have in
this case is at the top we have someone
who is highly likely to install a
subscribe or buy we have segment B which
is kind of middle of the road there's
someone somewhat likely to buy and then
segment C is someone who's really not
going to we don't think that they're
going to buy subscriber install
so the way that you would reach these
segments can vary so for the very first
segment segment a we know that these
users are likely to take the action that
we want they're going to convert anyways
so my position there is don't do
anything at all don't spend a lot of
time on these users because they're
already primed to do what we're asking
them to do
uh where you'd want to spend your time
is on segment B so the someone somewhat
likely to install audience and you
that's where you can have some sort of
intervention whether that be an in-game
offer
or some site uh sort of action that's
going to incentivize uh this specific
segment to convert
and then finally for audience segment C
because we know these users aren't going
to install a subscriber by this is at
inventory or ad slots that you should
set aside for a third party or an avid
Advertiser because they're not going to
let add a lot of value to your business
so you can set it set it aside for
someone who's buying media from you
so moving uh into the next section on ML
monetization strategy and measuring
return this it will get a little product
focused uh we wanted to quickly
introduce everyone to vertex AI but
essentially the key takeaway of this
section is in order to really evolve
your ml strategy you're going to want to
lean into machine learning operations
Automation and then proving impact your
business is very important having those
data nuggets to back up your efforts is
important as well so we'll also speak to
how you can leverage a b experiments to
better measure return to your business
so Google uh is essentially we're in
love with machine learning we live and
Breathe by it so we want as many people
as possible to leverage machine learning
uh so essentially what we've done is
we've created these three prescriptive
paths that customers can take so that
hopefully we can meet every user where
they are in their AI Journey so I'm
going to go from left to right which is
out of the box to custom or DIY but the
first path is essentially just
leveraging pre-trained apis so you'll
ping an endpoint you'll get a response
back there's no training of a model that
needs to be done and you can easily get
some sort of prediction and leverage it
to your needs
the middle of the road path is something
that Mike talked talked about in the
earlier section but we have what we call
low code or no code Solutions so
bigquery machine learning is a SQL based
Solution that's built into our data
warehouse you can iterate experiment
really quickly automl is essentially a
UI based way to build out state of the
state-of-the-art models so you don't
necessarily need to be an ml engineer or
PhD level data scientist to leverage
that middle of the road path
however we know that gaming companies
leverage machine learning day in and day
out so if you do have the ml Engineers
if you do have the PHD level data
scientists we do have the tooling that
you need to build your own custom models
models as well
uh so starting with the pre-trained apis
so we have pre-trained apis to address
machine learning problems related to
Vision language conversation so there's
a lot of different flavors of these
pre-trained apis we also have an automl
counterpart each pre-trained API so if
you want to use your own data in a low
code way there's that option as well
but very easy to use we maintain these
these models for you so there's nothing
that you need to do on your part you
just ask for a prediction back and we
send it to you
so this is a bit of an eyesore but this
is the the thousand foot view of all the
great things that fall under vertex AI
from a custom modeling standpoint I'm
not going to walk you through every
single product that we have within the
suite but I can touch on a few of the
foundational pieces in my opinion so a
workbench is a key part of vertex AI
essentially that is our Jupiter notebook
environment where you would train your
own custom model or build your own
machine learning pipelines that's
definitely a key piece within the tool
set
the other service that's important is
our training service which you can use
to obviously train your models our
prediction service can allow you to get
predictions back in batch or an online
scenario so gaming companies typically
care about real-time inference tasks so
we can definitely leverage our
prediction service to do that
and then one other piece that we wanted
to talk about and we'll actually spend a
little time on this is vertex AI
pipelines so we know that models are
trained on a snapshot of time in a
snapshot in time and we know that user
Behavior
or player behavior is going to change as
well so leveraging uh pipelines and
machine learning pipelines to automate
the retraining and monitoring of your
models is definitely important as you
want to as you evolve your ml strategy
um so at Google Cloud we love to do a
lot of user research so what was
interesting is uh the product team who's
developing vertex AI they did multiple
studies and essentially what they
learned is that data scientists are
building tons of models they're
experimenting they're doing great work
but a lot of times a lot that work is
done in vain because those models never
make it into production so the stat that
we've seen inside and out is that more
than 87 percent of machine learning
projects never make it into production
so our product teams went back to the
drawing board and tried to figure out
you know how can we help these data
scientists and these ml Engineers
actually action off these models that
they're training
so previously vertex AI was known as the
cloud AI platform it received a facelift
about two or three years ago and there's
a lot of advantages that came with this
new and improved version of our AI
platform uh so like I was mentioning or
mentioning earlier we added a lot of
tooling to enhance machine learning
operations so it's very easy to lean
into machine learning pipelines and
retraining your models out of the gate
we unified the data and AI experience so
going back to what was my what Mike was
saying earlier data and the data
strategies definitely foundational to
doing AI well so we wanted to make sure
that our tooling made it that much
easier for AI practitioners to tap into
the data that they need to train their
models so there's unification there we
also talked about the three different
ways that you can train models on cloud
so we have a custom solution we have the
low code no code Solutions
we also have the pre-trained apis
so with our the new tooling you also
have a more centralized way to keep
track of all these different models that
are available within vertex AI
and then the final thing that I'll talk
about
um and just briefly touch on we also
released a lot of algorithms that were
only previously used at Google for for
our own commercially facing products uh
so one example is vizier vizier is a
hyper parameter tuning service that we
use for our own apps we really believed
in this service and we wanted to provide
it it to Enterprises so there's several
algorithms that were internal to Google
that are now available for customers to
use out of the box
so a lot going on in this slide but I
just wanted to highlight this slide in
that all the pieces that we talked
through in that thousand foot view of
vertex AI has a place in a home within
within a larger machine learning
workflow so at the end of the day we do
want what practitioners and gaming
companies to leverage each piece of
vertex AI if possible so we want you to
use our training service we want you to
house all of your different models
within our model registry and Deploy on
our prediction service and monitor for
training serving SKU within our
Monitoring Service as well
how are we doing on time good
um so the next thing that we'll talk
about is vertex AI pipelines so even if
you are building a relatively
um straightforward model so churn isn't
necessarily the most advanced machine
learning use case it's very impactful
but I wouldn't say it's super Advanced
uh but with even simple models you want
to retrain these models to make sure
that they're performing well you want to
monitor when them when they're in
production to make sure that there's not
a degradation of performance over time
so that's where vertex AI pipelines
becomes really important so with vertex
AI pipelines we support two common
orchestrators and I'm sure a few people
in this room have heard of we support
kubeflow and tensorflow extended if you
are a machine learning shop that loves
tensorflow as a framework tfx is a great
option to leverage we've seen that by
and large clients are leveraging Cube
flow to to build out their machine
learning pipeline so it's really nice
that we have multiple options from an
orchestration standpoint
uh vertex AI pipelines is very scalable
and what we mean by that is you can
leverage and run as many pipelines as
you want it's cost effective in that you
only pay for the resources that you use
and then there's additional benefits
like metadata tracking so as you run
these machine learning pipelines
artifacts are going to be produced and
with the machine learning metadata store
it's really easy to backtrack within a
pipeline to understand what might be
causing issues or to help debug
all right so I think we're actually to
the final slide so we wanted to briefly
touch on experimentation uh we're not
going to belabor this too much but in
addition to leveraging machine learning
to enhance monetization you can use a b
experiments and experimentation to
better quantify impact to someone's
business
so this can take a lot of different
forms a b experimentation itself is a
very broad topic but if we go back to
some of the use cases that we were
talking about earlier recommendations
systems being one one way that this
could work is you could leverage a
testing platform to serve up a
personalized experience to one set of
users that has those recommendations
embedded in it and then have a more
generic experience and serve that up to
another set of users you then compare
the downstream impact on your business
and that's one way to quantify the
impact of personalization and how that
impacted monetization
um the the chart on the left hand side
shows an analysis that you can do after
you do geo experiments but that's
another great way to leverage a b
experimentation for those of you who
aren't familiar at its basic form with
the Geo experiment what you do is divvy
up geographical markets and to test and
control groups that are similar you then
will have some sort of intervention so
let's say we're trying to understand the
impact of a promotion you would then
have that promotion within the test
markets you would hold out that
intervention within your control markets
and then quantify the downstream
Downstream impact
so machine learning enhances
monetization but I feel like the a b
experiments can help add additional
color to how your driving business
impact so it's something to think
through as you evolve over time
I think that's everything so we'll uh
we'll start with any q a so I'll open it
up to the floor
that might have to Journey forward a
little bit
five minutes
yeah right next to the projector there
so when I got to where I am now
um we had the data was obviously a mess
to your point it usually is right it's
an eight-year-old game
um we did a lot of work we unified it we
cleaned it we got marketing and and
in-game data together right so we're now
back at a place where we can do machine
learning but because we did it because
we did it you know not with Google
um we're we're not using your services
so my question is if you already have a
dedicated
data set up like a like a data stack
with data governance and clean trustable
data that's all connected and not siled
is it possible to use some of the tools
that you mentioned for machine learning
on top of things like snowflake or AWS
yeah so there's a decent amount of
effort that we've put into the open
source side of the house so
um things like Apache beam is like a
version of being able to take some of
the ideas that we have at Google but
then also use them in a number of
different uh Cloud providers or
instances whether that be snowflake or
redshift kind of whatever it may be
um as well as some of our ml tools
things like keep flow are also open
source so some of the things that we see
here
our uh Google flavored but a lot of the
underlying technology itself is is open
source so if you want to tackle a lot of
these uh instances using different
Technologies as long as the principles
that you put into place are are sound
the technology itself that you use
implemented is awesome thank you very
much fantastic I don't know if you
noticed me like shaking my head yeah I
wanted to add additional colors so um
Mike and I are actually working on a
project that's very similar to this so
like one approach that we're thinking
through is let's say you built a model
in a different Cloud one approach could
be you know saving model artifacts
within cloud storage in our case and you
could then use it to deploy that model
on Google Cloud so you don't necessarily
need to be locked in which is one
advantage of Google Cloud that's awesome
yeah thank you so much
[Music]
oh yeah my question's about like
Firebase sort of does a lot of this user
segmentation for pre-existing
applications so like what does it look
like to then connect this to bigquery
which may be like another platform you
could have like overlapping user
segmentations going on how does that
work
for sure so Firebase is a another
fantastic example of a technology that
is built with the idea in mind of from
one platform we'd like you to be able to
tackle uh multiple different use cases
so usually where we see Firebase
implemented is in the context of things
like Mobile gaming
um but what we'll say is since that's
part of our overall strategy in order to
work with and operate data there are
built-in connectors that can have you
land that data in bigquery so that if
your use case starts to span outside of
just the realm of what Firebase is
capable of you'd like to start tackling
more advanced things you can start
diving into that with some of the
built-in connectors that we have but
also Firebase itself we're looking to
try to evolve in its own capabilities so
stuff to handle there for sure
uh yesterday I wanted to ask so when you
were defining the users as good and bad
I was thinking if you consider anything
I don't know from a different
perspective maybe from ethical
considerations or was just good user
High Revenue but user low Revenue
I see what you're saying um yeah so a
lot of times when you when you're
sorting through these different model
outputs a lot a lot of times it's
arbitrary but one thing that I will say
about Google cloud is we really are
focused on responsible AI
so we didn't this really kind of Falls
outside of the scope of this discussion
today but we do have tooling like
explainable AI model monitoring which is
meant to help you understand you know
out of all of your users are the
predictions Equitable and not biased
um so I would say that we do have a
separate set of tooling that you can use
to make sure that you are being more
Equitable and responsible we just didn't
cover it today just because it wasn't
really within scope
thank you good question now yeah yeah
and just one quick note on that there's
when you start to make these buckets of
players the
how you identify them isn't necessarily
the end all be-all of how you advertise
or Market to them
um it really should just establish like
here are the players player delineations
themselves uh how do I want to what's my
strategy to approach them so if it seems
like they're low value players is there
and this is where things like game data
Telemetry come into play is that because
of the experience that they're having is
there something that we need to fix for
them further Upstream that's preventing
them from uh being willing to spend on
skin or whatever in-game offer you're
interested in so
um it's not necessarily that we want
people to instantly give up on that uh
that user base it's really just hey
we've identified this because we have
the data now let's take action on it
fantastic uh we'll be around to answer
any other questions but thank you so
much for your time
[Applause]